change is inevitable but growth is
optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm ramad RAF from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aimed for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiting
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and then it offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive is that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete a master's
program including artificial
intelligence cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
keep learning keep growing